[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فهي الادوات التي لجا اليها الغرب فيما
يتعلق بالتجاره مثل القيود التي فرضت على
استيراد التكنولوجيا الحساسه وبالتالي
عانت مؤسسه التصنيع العسكري من مسائل
هيكليه لفتره طويله وعانت من التنافسيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اصبحت الصناعات العسكريه الروسيه تعاني
كثيرا وتعطلت سلسله الامداد وهناك قيود
ايضا على تصدير الرقائق والمواصلات
الدقيقه ما جعل التصنيع العسكري الروسي
يعاني من شده النقص بمواد الانتاج معطل
انتاج الدبابات والاسلحه التي تفوق سرعه
الصوت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الصناعات العسكريه الروسيه تعاني نفس
المشكلات التي تواجه هذه الصناعه عالميا
مثل نقص العماله والمواد اللازمه
والعقوبات الدوليه تزيد الطين بالله من
خلال عدم التمكن من الحصول على الامدادات
بشكل يمكنهم من استكمال مراحل الانتاج
العسكري
وذلك لسببين رئيسيين اولهما ان التكنوقراط
الروس ادار هذه الازمه بشكل جيد باستخدام
التكتيك اتبعوه منذ العقوبات التي فرضت
على روسيا في عقاب ضمها للقرد
[موسيقى]